Це дуже добре що ми нарешті починаємо
колаборантів і тих хто
отримує ордени Пушкіна і
співпрацює із нашим ворогом позбавлятися
Тим більше що у цієї особи дуже цікава
біографія пов'язана із криміналом і з
нападом на журналістів та чого там
тільки немає але з іншого боку у нас
залишаються в залі продовжувати
залишатися в залі колаборанти які після
2014 року до 2014 року завжди казали що
Росія друг
ми чомусь не розглядаємо зареєстровано
постанову про припинення повноважень
опзж тих хто був обраний за списками
цієї партії Ти хто завжди закликав
довіритися і домовитися з Путіним
здатися фактично а партія ця опзж уже
верховним судом на сьогоднішній день
заборонено проте я розумію чому ми
сьогодні не розглядаємо цю постанову про
те щоби опзж більше не було в сесійній
залі колаборантів вигнати звідси Хоча є
для цього юридичні постанови тому що
монобільшість у якої не вистачає голосів
для моно більшості сьогодні добирає от
як прямо зараз хоч і не вистачило голоси
від уламків того опзж мало того всі з
ними нормально розмовляють всі з ними
нормально домовля
це і навіть за свободу слова сьогодні
відповідає людина в комітет очолює який
відповідає за свободу слова та людина
яка закликала домовитися з Путіним і яка
є найближчим соратником кума Путіна Ось
і Дивіться що у нас сьогодні
відбувається Ми звичайно проголосуємо за
але колаборанти мають зникнути з
Верховної Ради України назавжди і якщо
ми цього не голосуємо то один персонал